[موسيقى]
خلال هذه الايام وحنا طالعين من وقت صلاه
الفجر نبي نشاهد جرم سماوي خافت وقريب من
الافق ثابت الاضاءه ولؤلؤيا اللون وين
بالجهه الشرقيه هذا هو كوكب عطارد وعطارد
اصغر افراد المجموعه الشمسيه واقربها الى
الشمس واول من سماه عطارد هم العرب وعطارد
ماخوذه من مصدر طرد وهو المتسارع في حركته
قد لاح في ليل شباب كواكب ان امهلت اله
الى الاسفار يا كوكبا ما كان اقصر عمره
وكذاك عمرك واكب
الاسحار
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وتسميه العرب للكواكب والنجوم مبنيه على
ما تتسم او تتصف به فاسموا الزهره ليه
لانها تزهو بجمالها واسموا سهيلا لان
الاجواء تتسهل عند رؤيته اما الرومان فقد
اسموا عطارد بماركوري وهي الهه السماء
المليحه ومليحه ترمي السهام سديده بالحسن
اما الفكر غير سديد تدعو الى الالحاد في
كلماتها وجمالها يدعو
الى التوحيد
[موسيقى]